it feels real doesn't it the sand on  your skin the taste in your mouth you  are no longer death row inmates you are  contestants on the greatest game show in  the world the Jurassic Games  this is the most controversial cast  we've seen on the jurassic games in  years isn't this really nothing more  than exploitation of these contestants  you are essentially torturing them on  live television public execution is  nothing new my client maintains his  innocence  I'm not here to kill anybody I'm here to  kill everybody  I am NOT the judge I correct we are not  the dress but the game is the execution  wait wait wait not yet not yeah  three  to  you